hey you know the nevada department of
transportation wants you to sign
in you may remember back in august they
announced a contest for short snappy
messages that could end up
on some or all of the state's 400 or so
overhead signs
well they've narrowed the field of
potential winners down to 11.
now ndot wants you to vote for your top
three from these entries
when driving use your thinker and your
blinker that's the temperature not the
speed
texts means wrecks it's not a race leave
some space
there's no need to drive at warp speed
practice vehicle social distancing don't
tailgate your seat belt looks good on
you
gamble at the casino not your car buckle
up camp in the mountains
not the left lane turn signals come free
with vehicles use them don't get
exhausted tailgating blows
all right so only one entry per person
you have to be 16 to vote you've got
until june 15th to vote at dot.nv.gov
side so that link and all the entries
there on our website on the online
version of this story eightnewsnow.com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there's something driving to crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com